[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn wir an krieg denken sie die ersten
bilder die den meisten von uns durch den
kopf gehen die von panzern bomben
raketen und soldaten mit großen
sturmgewehren inmitten eines
schlachtfeldes die wahrheit ist jedoch
dass sich diese dinge in letzter zeit
verändern und zwar sehr stark verändern
diese art von kriegen wir sie mal
traditionelle kriegsführung scheint vom
aussterben bedroht zu sein zumindest
soweit es die supermächte betrifft
ja du hast richtig gehört ausgerechnet
jene länder die historisch gesehen die
aktivsten militär rechte sind wie die
usa oder russland sind immer weniger
daran beteiligt zur verteidigung ihrer
interessen mächtige truppenkontingente
ist ausland zu entsenden warum nun weil
diese art von operation nicht nur einen
enormen finanziellen aufwand in bezug
auf wachen transport und alle arten von
logistik mit sich bringen sondern auch
einen hohen preise in bezug auf
menschenleben haben ein faktor der in
der heimat änderung schwerer
durchzusetzen ist während des zweiten
weltkriegs des korea kriegs und so
beginn des kriegs legte die gesellschaft
eben noch mehr wert auf das erreichen
der kriegsziele als auf das leben der
soldaten mit der zeit hat sich jedoch
die politische und gesellschaftliche
sensibilität für die menschlichen kosten
des krieges verändert in der tat können
wir heute sagen dass die kriege in irak
und in afghanistan in dieser hinsicht
echte historische wendepunkte waren
nichts wird mehr so sein wie vorher
in diesem video wollen wir daher eine
vorstellung davon vermitteln wie die
nahe zukunft der modernen kriegsführung
aussehen könnte
special operations
das heißt jene klinischen militär
operationen mit beispielsweise folgende
ziele eine aufständische bewegung
stärken oder schwächen politisches oder
gesellschaftliches chaos in einem
feindlichen land führen indem man
schlüsselpersonen ausschaltet oder
kritische teil der infrastruktur lahm
legt oder in guerilla kriege und
irreguläre stadt asymmetrischen konflikt
eingreifen
just cause alive sozusagen all das hängt
natürlich von den interessen der
jeweiligen macht ab wenn es zum beispiel
im interesse der usa ist eine bestimmte
gruppe zu stärken die generation der
iranischen ayatollahs feindlich gesinnt
ist könnten sie ein kommando
spezialkräfte entsenden um diese gruppen
zu unterstützen auszurüsten zu beraten
und auszubilden
bei dieser art von operationen spielt
die konventionelle armee lediglich eine
unterstützende rolle wenn zum beispiel
das kommando der special forces probleme
bei seinen missionen hat und unterstützt
oder evakuiert werden muss greift die
konventionelle armee an diesem punkt ein
fast das problem nicht mit einem anderen
special operations team gelöst werden
kann
du siehst also die karten werden neu
gemischt daher trägt sich sofort die
frage auf welche länder können auf
globaler ebene eine wirklich relevante
rolle raus den immer bedeutender
werdenden feld der spezialoperationen
spielen nun sicherlich gibt es dafür
eine ganze reihe von kandidaten
aber in diesem video werden wir einen
blick auf die fähigkeiten der drei
hauptakteure in dieser neuen art des
multilateralen kalten kriegs werfen die
usa russland und china könnten special
operations und nicht konventionelle
kriegsführung die zukunft der
kriegsführung und gar politische
auseinandersetzungen seien
schauen wir uns das mal etwas genauer an
die elite der elite kleine frage am
rande wenn du die elitesoldaten
vorstellst was kommt jeder zuerst in den
sinn
ich hätte dir schwebt in etwa das folgte
bild wort special force das als kleine
gruppe von erstklassig ausgerüsteten
soldaten mit high tech waffen und 80
geräten wärmekameras und einer menge
anderem technische spielzeug jagd so
kennen wir sie denn so werden sie uns
auf der großen leinwand präsentiert aber
wie funktioniert das alles wirklich nun
um sie besser kennenzulernen schauen wir
uns mal die kommandos der united states
has an vermutlich die weltweit besten
auf ihrem gebiet
[Musik]
die modernen us special forces wie wir
sie heute kennen wurden während des
zweiten weltkriegs geschaffen später als
in den 80er jahren der kalte krieg druck
zu setzen die vereinigten staaten solche
kommandos hauptsächlich unter der
leitung der st
wir sprechen von kommandos die mission
arzt durchführen
von der ausbildung und unterstützung von
warlords in afghanistan bis zum kampf
gegen pablo escobars kartell oder die
farc rebellen in kolumbien im jahr 2001
nachdem elfter september kam es jedoch
zu einem strategiewechsel und die
spezialkräfte wird dann innerhalb der
armee an bedeutung zu dringen hierzu
koordiniert eine zentrale stelle dass
die usk operations command kurz usv com
mit sitz in tampa florida die
verschiedenen spezialeinheiten der us
army air force navy und das marie chor
und diese koordinierungsarbeit ist eine
wahre herkulesaufgabe denn heute haben
die usa schätzungsweise 70.000 kräfte
von denen sich etwa 13.000 gleichzeitig
im einsatz auf der ganzen welt befinden
vor allem im nahen osten aber auch an
orten wie lettland und korea wie sie zb
südkoreanische spezialkräfte ausbilden
um die das gewaltige wachstum der
amerikanischen spezialkräfte zu
verdeutlichen
im jahr 2001 hatten die usa nur knapp
3000 und heute rund 70.000
[Applaus]
diese mehr als 22 warum ist vor allem
aufnahmen eleven zurückzuführen denn die
regierung sowie die busse erklärte
spezialkräfte zum schlüsselelement des
kriegs gegen den terrorismus und sowohl
obama als auch jobs setzen diese politik
konsequent fort die navy seals oder
delta force zuvor vor allem aus action
filmen bekannt sind zum fundamentalen
bestandteil der us außenpolitik geworden
ihr haupteinsatzgebiet ist die
bekämpfung von terror und aufständen zum
beispiel haben die us spezialkräfte den
großteil ihrer arbeit im kampf gegen und
al qaida im irak und auch in afghanistan
geleistet sie haben auch irakische und
afghanische kräfte trainiert damit diese
in der lage sind selbst einigermaßen
attraktiv zu kooperieren ihre
operationen werden normalerweise nicht
in den medien hervorgehoben und zu den
vielen fällen nicht einmal öffentlich
bekannt ohne sie würden aber viele
dieser radikalen gruppen heute
wahrscheinlich viel stärker dastehen
schauen wir uns also mal einen konkreten
fall an ich bin mir sicher ihr erinnert
euch alle an die eliminierung von osama
bin laden in pakistan richtig diese
bilder gingen damals um die ganze welt
barack obama erteilte den befehl oder
navy seals kommando bestehend aus zwei
dutzend elite soldaten unterstützt von
cia-agenten landete mit einem
hubschrauber in der nähe des hauses in
dem bin laden dank der geheimdienste
entdeckt worden war
die operation verlief schnell eine gute
tante angriff der alle ziele
neutralisierte inklusive des ikonischen
al kaida führers diese intervention
verlief wie im lehrbuch und wenn man den
modus operandi eines spezialkommandos
definieren müsste wäre diese operationen
das paradebeispiel ein anderes
exzellentes beispiel bei ganz anderer
art der durchführung war eine
entsorgungs aktion die anfangs 2020 auf
betitelt trump selbeck das durchgeführt
wurde
die regierung des iranischen generals
kaserne soleimani anstatt ein kommando
loszuschicken das physisch gegen seine
wachen kämpfen müsste wurde ganz einfach
eine drohne eingesetzt aber wenn du
jetzt denkst dass diese operation
einfach nur ein simpler drohnenangriffs
du dich gewaltig denn was nur wenig
bekannt ist auch in diesem fall folgt
ein fahrzeug der us spezialkräfte ist
alice kunden wollen und nur dank dieses
kommandos bekamen die drei piloten die
notwendigen informationen um ihr ziel
erfolgreich linien zu können überrascht
nun warte ab was als nächstes kommt denn
neben dieser art von chirurgischen
eingriffen um anführer oder
schlüsselpersonen auszuschalten gibt es
noch andere arten von operationen bei
dem spezialkräfte typischerweise sehr
effizient sind wir sprechen über viele
riskante operationen bei denen russland
eine erstaunliche und höchst
beunruhigende kompetenz bewiesen hat
hast du schon eine vorahnung worauf wir
hinauswollen
dann lass das jetzt mal herausfinden
stille invasionen russland verfügt über
elite einheiten die sich auf stille
invasionen spezialisiert haben die
gefürchteten spezial noch genau da ist
man ja kurz bett nass sie verfügen über
17.000 mann und mischen sich überall
dort ein wo der russische bär seinen
einflussbereich verteidigung oder
ausweiten will
so zum beispiel in osteuropa gesprächen
von jener art von invasion die ganz
still abläuft ohne zunächst von
irgendjemandem bemerkt zu werden so gut
wie ohne zerstörungen und boote
natürlich nur solange niemand im weg
steht ein beispiel war der russische
einmarsch auf der halbinsel krim im jahr
2014 aus militärischer sicht praktisch
ein historischer meilenstein
man muss sich die fakten dass du schon
auf der zunge zergehen lassen
ein gebiet zu erobern fast so groß wie
das bundesland brandenburg mit etwas
mehr als zwei millionen einwohnern ohne
einen einzigen schuss abzufeuern ist
ohne zweifel etwas sehr beeindruckend
ist plötzlich und ohne dass es jemand
aufhalten konnte begannen aufmerksamen
mysteriöse soldaten ohne kennzeichnung
aufzutauchen sie waren einfach zu gut
ausgerüstet um als irreguläre kämpfer
oder rebellen durchzugehen und sie
schien auch eine militärische elite
formation zu besitzen
wir sprechen von den sogenannten kleinen
grünen männchen welche quasi über nacht
die kontrolle über die schlüssel
infrastruktur der regierung krim
übernahmen verkehrsknotenpunkte
kraftwerke medien alle hauptstellen der
öffentlichen verwaltung usw
das alles praktisch ohne gewaltanwendung
und nebenbei bemerkt das hier ist ein
ganz anderes szenario als im donbass
natürlich geschah all das das ist uns
gesagt werden mit der logistischen und
militärisch geheimdienstlichen
unterstützung der konventionellen
russischen armee die schon zuvor eine
marine basis in sewastopol unterhielt
den haupt stützpunkt der russischen
schwarzmeerflotte
was jedoch erst viel später ans licht
kam und auch heute noch vielen nicht
bekannt ist putin verbrachte wochen
damit verstärkungen nach sewastopol zu
schicken
in form von bodentruppen die eingreifen
sollten falls die spezialkräfte ist
nicht alleine hinbekommen würden und das
ist der generelle trend der letzten
jahre
spezialeinheiten agieren nicht mehr
isoliert wie es vielleicht in den 70er
80er und 90er jahren der fall war
sondern in enger koordination mit
konventionellen streitkräften deswegen
sind jetzt supermächten ihre militär
basen und strategischen allianzen in der
ganzen welt so wichtig und deswegen
wollen sie diese ständig erweitern
[Musik]
ich bin mir sicher dass viele von euch
die enorme militärische und territoriale
expansions- chinas in den ländern
südostasiens verfolgen zb den streit um
die künstlichen inseln im
südchinesischen meer
denn gerade in kombination mit dem was
wir gerade gesehen haben verstehst wer
ist wenn du um militärische kontrolle in
einem bestimmten territorium aus obst
kannst du sehr leicht auch die staaten
in der nähe kontrollieren und obwohl die
chinesische spezialeinheiten noch in den
kinderschuhen stecken ist es eine
tatsache dass peking bereits seit den
1990 er jahren keine kosten und mühen
gescheut um seine elitetruppen auf das
niveau der amerikaner und russen zu
bringen bis zum neugierig geworden wie
sich gegen die zukunft der sogenannten
volksbefreiungsarmee vorstellt dann
schauen wir uns das ist doch mal ein
die dreiteilung der welt
nach all dem was wir in diesem video
erzählt haben sollte klar sein dass der
unterschied zwischen einer guten armee
und einer einflussreichen streitkraft
mit der man auf globaler ebene
maßgebliche veränderungen militärisch
durchsetzen kann
in den spezialkräften liegt ja okay du
kannst viele panzer beeindruckende
jagdbomber und mächtige verbände von
fregatten und flugzeugträgern haben aber
welche staat wäre schon dazu bereit all
diese kräfte auf einmal in die schlacht
zu werfen ein totaler krieg ist so
riskant kostspielig und unpopulär wie
nie zuvor
wieso sollte man ansetzen wenn es eine
elegantere alternative gibt die diskrete
schneller und mit unendlich weniger
wirtschaftlichen und menschlichen kosten
verbunden ist nun genau aus all diesen
gründen ist das land das derzeit die
größten anstrengungen unternimmt seine
handlungsfähigkeit mit spezialkräften zu
erhöhen
kein anderes als das chinesische
riesenreich es hat nicht nur einen
sondern gleich mehrere elite verbände
aufgebaut
tatsächlich hat jede heeresgruppe in
welcher die volksbefreiungsarmee oder
zeit ist ihre eigene eliteeinheit anders
als die usa und russland das tut jedoch
ausgerechnet das zentralistische china
über keine zentrale kommandostelle
welche die elitetruppen koordinieren
würde aber trotzdem auch diesel verbände
sind durchaus beeindruckt
die marine verfügt über die jungs zu
deutsch seedrachen sie wurden 2002
gegründet und haben unter anderem ein
von somalischen piraten gekapertes
frachtschiff im golf von aden befreit
eine weitere top einheit der chinesische
spezialkräfte sind die leichen der
luftwaffe
das kuriose an diesen fallschirmjäger
kommando ist das ist an der
militärakademie der bolivarischen
nationalgarde venezuelas ausgebildet
wurde
um sich auf den kampf im dschungel zu
spezialisieren und wir könnten jetzt so
endlos weitermachen 15 16 und mehr
spezialeinheiten mit
verschiedenartigsten spezialisierungen
aufzählen denn zurzeit ist nicht bekannt
wie viele soldaten diese einheiten
umfassen
aber es wird geschätzt dass diese zahl
irgendwo zwischen 7.000 und 10.000 liegt
ja das scheint weit entfernt zu sein von
den 70.000 ob mäßig ausgebildeten und
hoch gerüsteten einheiten des chors aber
was wir nicht vergessen dürfen noch vor
20 jahren verfügten die usa auch nicht
über viel mehr als 3000 soldaten mit
anderen worten dieser unterschied ist
viel schneller aufzuholen als man auf
den ersten blick denken könnte
[Applaus]
und freunde wenn china schafft seine
spezialkräfte vollstellen nicht
aufzubauen
könnten wir von einem neuen paradigma
der militärischen weltordnung stehen
einem szenario in dem die drei großen
supermächte in der lage wären auf
augenhöhe in komplexe operation
einzugreifen
diskret günstig wird schnell
asymmetrisch und ohne eigenes risiko
welches konventioneller kriegsführung
mit sich brächte die hemmschwelle zum
krieg wird für sie somit immer weiter
abgesenkt diese inflation an operationen
könnte die zukunft vieler länder
beeinflussen oder gänzlich verändert
ihre innenpolitik ganze regierungen und
regierungsformen stürzen oder stützen
und rebellengruppen heranzüchten welche
dann irgendwann außer kontrolle geraten
und endlosen terror verbreiten aber
wartet einen moment wenn wir eine
galoppierende inflation dieser art von
intervention erleben sollten wohin wird
dies die welt führen hätten russland und
china überhaupt skrupel sich in ländern
einzumischen die mit den usa verbündet
sind gar in etablierten demokratien
konflikte zu schüren könnte dies am ende
zu einem konflikt zwischen diesen
großmächten selbst führen befinden wir
uns auf der schwelle zu einem zeitalter
eines ganz neuen kalten krieg ist
diesmal mit drei supermächten welche die
welt untereinander aufteilen und zur
ausweitung ihrer imperien überall auf
der welt stellvertreter konflikte oder
instabilität führen werden
ja wir werden uns sehr in acht nehmen
müssen denn viele experten sagen voraus
dass es zu einem exklusiven risiko für
die internationale sicherheit werden
könnte wenn die größenwahnsinnigen
politiker der supermächte plötzlich über
10.000 sogar hunderttausende von
hochgradig gefährlichen agenten verfügen
in der lage sind kontinuierlich in
dieser art von verdeckten operation zu
agieren eine zeitbombe für zukünftige
konflikte in größerem maßstab denn
allein die komplexität so viele
chirurgische operation könnte wieder in
einer unkontrollierbaren eskalation den
totalen krieg gründen oder aber auch in
einem zeitalter ewiger kriege die nie
richtig erklärt und nie beendet werden
können aber alle menschen auf
generationen hinweg in einem stecken
zustand der spaltung und und sicherheit
halten werden du siehst also neue
strategien bringt typischerweise
vorteile aber auch risiken die wir nicht
ignorieren können aber jetzt bist du an
der reihe
glaubst du dass der wahlloser einsatz
von spezialkräften für auslandseinsätze
eine nützliche chance oder ein risiko
für die globale stabilität ist denkst du
dass dies die zukunft der bewaffneten
konfrontation sein könnte steht das
zeitalter des neuen kalten kriegs vor
der tür
und was wäre in diesem fall besser ein
ende mit schrecken oder ein schrecken
ohne ende
teilt eure meinung wird er immer mit uns
und auch alle anderen ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat was ja
geht uns bereithalten folgten und
vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren
was gut bis bald